Milk, it's one of my favorite drinks.
>> Especially when you have fresh baked cookies
right out of the oven. I love it.
>> Hm, but, not everyone can enjoy
such a delicious combination. After drinking milk
or other dairy products, like all food, it travels to the stomach, where the
body continues to break down the food
into smaller components for energy. Now the
cells within the stomach control what gets
into the body. Lactose, a main ingredient of
all dairy products, is composed of two smaller
sugars that together are too big to get past
the stomach cell lining. So these cells produce an
enzyme called lactase, that is secreted to digest the
two ring lactose into the separate sugars, glucose and
galactose, which can readily pass through the stomach's cell
lining, into the body for further metabolism. Without lactase,
lactose would travel right through the body undigested until
it reaches the colon where bacteria end up breaking the lactose down using
a fermentation process that produces a lot of gas. This also throws off
the water balance in the body, leading to an increased flow of water
to the bowels which results in, you guessed it, symptoms of lactose intolerance.
>> That sounds like no fun. I don't think I'd like to be lactose intolerant.
>> It's really not that bad guys.
>> Hey Hsiao-Lu, I didn't know you were lactose intolerant.
>> That's right,
I am. As a baby, I was able to drink
milk. But as I got older, I stopped being able to
process it. So, what that means is that I'm unable to
eat anything that contains dairy products, like cheese and ice cream.
>> Ooh.
>> Yeah, but.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> You know, the consequences are such that you want to avoid them.
>> Genetically speaking, why do you think
Hsao-Lu's lactose intolerant? Choose one of these
answers, and then tell me why by typing a response in this text box.